salut romain ça va attention derrière
toi sur marc morandini vous avez sans
doute déjà été atteint par une crise de
mieux clos ni fresneau glottique plus
connu sous le nom de thomas le hockey il
se passe deux phénomènes
d'abord nos muscles respiratoires c'est
à dire notamment le diaphragme se
contracte brutalement et ça pour
conséquence d'expulser tout d'un coup
l'air qu'on a dans les pouilles bon ok
mais normalement quand on expire même
très fort ça fait pas de ce genre de
bruit donc qu'est ce qui se passe et bat
dans le même temps l'ue l'épiglotte là
jusqu'au fond de la gorgue se contracte
pour empêcher l'air d'entrer et vibrer
les cordes vocales et ça provoque ce
bruit caractéristique connaît mal le
mécanisme exact mais il concerne
notamment le nerf phrénique qui innerve
le diaphragme et les nerf
pneumogastrique qu'on appelle aussi les
nerf vague en cas de hockey ses nerfs
serait excité pour diverses raisons
parce qu'on mange trop et trop vite par
exemple on écoute un petit peu ce petit
glouton
il ya d'autres situations dont on
suppose qu elle excite aussi on va dire
qu'elle irrite aussi les nerfs en
question comme par exemple quand on voit
trop d'alcool ou trop de boissons
gazeuses mais aussi d'autres causes
comme le tabac le stress les changements
brutaux de température le rire là tous
les émotions les conversations de
leicester de donald trump très attention
là on parle du hockey bénin un coquet
aiguë d'ailleurs celui qui arrive de
temps en temps et qui durent pas trop
longtemps même si bon ça peut être
pénible quand même mais le hockey peut
aussi durer plus de 48 heures voire
plusieurs jours voire plusieurs semaines
dans ces cas là il faut voir son médecin
ça peut avoir une origine un peu plus
sérieuse qu'un gros dôme à cavaler en
deux secondes
mais ça se soigne le reste du temps pour
faire passer un simple
ok les trucs habituels ces derniers
m deux grands mères si vous voulez ça
consiste à obliger le diaphragme à
arrêter ces petites simagrées en faisant
monter le taux de co2 dans le sang par
exemple ce qui alerte les centres
nerveux responsable de la respiration
qu'un truc pas normal est en train de se
passer et qu'il faut aller remettre de
leurs mains dedans c'est ce qu'on fait
quand on bloque sa respiration ou qu'on
respire très vite dans un sac en papier
mais ça perso je conseille pas c'est un
coiffeur un malaise et franchement un
malaise avec le hockey ça doit être bien
nul mais ça peut aussi consister à
stimuler les nerfs en cause pour faire
diversion genre faire peur avaler une
grande cuillère de sucre ou tirer sur sa
longue vers l'avant
sa propre langue médicalement des trucs
du même genre y en a des centaines
en 2006 il ya même un médecin qui a reçu
un prix ig nobel qui récompense les
recherches improbables mais sérieuse
pour son étude de cas qui cherchait à
démontrer l'intérêt du toucher rectal
pour faire passer une crise de hockey
rebelles il s'appelle francis fait ce
mayer bon il est décédé mais vous
imaginez si vous l'aviez vu comme
médecin traitant a doctor depuis ce
matin j'ai des migraines
alors pour mon diabète bon laisser
tomber je vous dois combien bon tous les
trucs peuvent marcher pour faire passer
un hockey même celui du docteur fès
mayer a marché au moins une fois mais
ils marchent pas pour tout le monde
sûrement comme vous j'ai essayé un
maximum de trucs sans réussir à trouver
celui qui marchaient à tous les coups et
puis très récemment j'ai découvert le
truc faisant des recherches dans un
vieux grimoire j'ai lu qu'un objet
magique était capable de faire passer le
hockey à tous les coups par le
truchement d'un prodige et cet objet
ce stade-là son bon alors mais qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait ce glaçons et ben on se le
mettre dans le nombril au début j'étais
comme vous se mettre un glaçon dans le
nombril pour faire passer le hockey
j'étais circonspecte on va dire surtout
qu'avant quand on cherche des
explications scientifiques à ça c'est
pas très convaincant mais j'ai quand
même tester et bien croyez le ou pas ça
a marché
à tous les coups encore mieux pour être
sûr de mon coup j'ai demandé à mon
entourage de tester et ça marche et tous
les coups pourquoi je parle comme ça
maintenant ce que je vous propose c'est
de participer
tous ensemble dans la joie et
l'allégresse a une grande expérience
la prochaine fois que vous aurez le
hockey munissez vous d'un glaçon et
placez le dans votre nombril puis faites
moi savoir si ça a marché pour vous ou
pas vous pouvez au film et c'est encore
mieux voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo
en attendant faire progresser la science
tous ensemble langer doucement prenez
soin de vous prenez soin des autres et
surtout hors t il